also erst mal die wahrheit was hätte ich
denn sagen sondern sagen nee eigentlich
wollte ich gar nicht so viel geld oder
immer das doch quatsch dass der betrag
der verabredet wurde für eine bestimmte
zeit und tätigkeit und ich meine es ist
sie haben ja selber über andere gehälter
in der politik von die allzu langer zeit
berichtet dagegen ist das ja noch
vergleichsweise erklärbar was wir da an
einnahmen hatten in der firma herr
bosbach 10.000 euro für sie viel oder
wenig geld
natürlich ist das viel geld für wen ist
das nicht viel geld als erster diese
lebhafte debatte hatten bin ich mal mein
bett gegangen hab mal gegoogelt was für
berater bezahlt wird das
strategieberatung die beratung
organisationsberatung eine große
bandbreite
ich lege jetzt nicht vielleicht ganz
richtig aber auch nicht ganz schief ich
schätze mal zwischen 1000 und
zweieinhalb tausend euro pro tag sind
der tagessätze für berater
ich weiß nicht ich kann auch nicht
wissen in welchem umfange sigmar gabriel
tätig war
aber fragen sie doch mal die
bundesregierung was die bundesregierung
in ihren ressorts insbesondere beim
verteidigungsministerium für top berater
nicht nur gezahlt hat sondern auch heute
noch sagt ich bin mir ziemlich sicher
wenn sie einmal unterstellen der monat
hat 20 21 arbeitstage dass sie mit
10.000 euro nicht hinbekommen habe
verstehen sie dennoch die kritik die
jetzt war einmal hott der eigenen partei
kommen die kollegen die sagen wie kann
man denn so etwas sagen das ist sowas
von abgehoben und der hat ja vollkommen
das gespür und die bodenhaftung verloren
und auch den bezug zu gerade dem
klassischen spd arbeiter klientel also
das mit dass alles sich freuen mögen sie
verstehen dass die beiden vorsitzenden
der spd in so eine kritik einstimmen
obwohl sie glaube ich gemeinsam in der
gleichen gehaltsgruppe liegen oder
deutlich darüber verwundert mich ein
bisschen
ich will das nicht kommentieren das ist
ein für eine beratertätigkeit antwort
eben richtig dargestellt kein
überzogenes gehalt dahinter steckt ja
auch eine firma aber ich bin ich da auch
nicht weiter rechtfertigen so ist das
und es gibt menschen die finden das
nicht gut und das muss ich akzeptieren
ich kann das nicht ändern